[Music]
hey everybody
what the hell day is it it's monday it's
monday yeah
weird kind of felt like tuesday for a
second it did actually that's why i was
uh confused for a moment but i was like
oh no i put that yeah i took out the
garbage this morning so it must be
monday got the new shirt
in there developing right now or the uh
what do you call it
the screenport hopefully it comes out
this time
yeah i mean yeah last time i had timing
problems it's an it's a new solution
that i'm using
yeah it's like i ordered the same [ __ ] i
just ordered like a big one
but it's a different color than the last
stuff even though it
said it was the same stuff that i bought
last time it didn't come with the exact
same
uh didn't come with any instructions on
development time so i thought it'd be
the same
but i'm using an led light bulb which
that's might be a problem too
because it's very white it's not a
scattered yellowish light
yeah and it's unsure the wattage
so we just it's kind of like trial and
error every time we get a new thing to
see like how long to like expose it for
four throw down us does the andromeda
stream have grits in it
it should there was a couple of times
where they showed some open
refrigerators and i didn't see any grits
uh yeah it's gonna be in the
refrigerator they would be in the pantry
they'd be in a pantry yeah
they could you're not you're not really
supposed to you're not really supposed
to reheat
used grits no they're not good you kind
of got to eat them like right when they
get cooked when they cool they kind of
set up like concrete
yeah and you can't really rescue them i
mean you can't you can
kind of you add a bunch of water to it
and break them up and heat them back up
again cook the water back out of them
but
[Laughter]
they're only a couple sets a cup you
know why are you doing that you know
cheap it is very easy to distract you
isn't it
that's all we have to do is start
putting a grip in a damn survival bin
i need some excess grits yeah we need
extra grip
grits in a number 10 can indestructible
grits on top of grits
yeah great fresh off the grit tree
with grit gravy and grit juice sprinkle
with grits
[Laughter]
sure yeah all right so do you want to
talk about the andromeda strength
yeah so i think what okay so what
happened with this one was that
as you sometimes happened in the patreon
poll like for the movie retrospective
that everyone was voting on
there was a tie between the andromeda
strain and what a stranger calls
so i just decided well we'll do win a
stranger calls for the
retrospective so we recorded that and
then we'll just do andromeda strain as a
live stream because i could have [ __ ]
sworn
that we had already done the andromeda
stream because i know we watched it not
too long ago
and i thought that we watched it to
review it but when i did a search
through my
through the channel i was like i
couldn't wasn't there it wasn't there
and drama no andromeda script strain
is a very realistic movie i saw when i
was a kid it kind of freaked me out
even though at the time i was probably
only about eight or nine i couldn't
grasp
everything that happened in it i just
knew it was scary
um and it was realistic it's kind of
like on on the um
on the level of 2001 a space odyssey
where you're dealing with uh a lot of
kind of dry
military and intelligence kind of guys
and in a big emergency that's happening
it's a
it's a uh it's a bio warfare event
and they get together a bunch of
scientists to try to figure out what the
hell
kind of [ __ ] bio weapon this is and
how how are they going to solve it
starts out with a whole town out in the
middle of the southwest get wiped out it
went southwest
yeah it was piedmont new mexico it was
the name of the town although they
actually shot it in a little town in
texas
find all these these guys go in there
and buy
suits and find all these uh civilians
just dead in their tracks
you know some of them they found out
later looked like they killed themselves
they went crazy and killed themselves
and there's two of them still alive old
man and a little baby
and that's they have to go to this ultra
secret
underground um
biodefense facility it's like a
laboratory
to try to figure out what the hell kind
of [ __ ]
biological agent this is and how it got
there and
i don't know if we're ready to spoil it
all of it but well it's an old movie and
i mean the
the book which is by michael creighton
came out in 1969 and the movie came out
in 1971
brighton does a lot of cool [ __ ] we've
covered a lot of his movies
yeah i mean probably most famous for
jurassic park but you know he did a [ __ ]
ton of other ones
and they've adapted pretty much every
one of the [ __ ] novels this was kind
of like one of his early ones
the interesting thing about this i mean
because he was a med
he's a medical doctor he was at least a
med student or he went through med
school or whatever
and he's really really really into
science and scientific accuracy and
particularly he was back then and i
think that he got the idea for the novel
the andromeda strain
from when they were talking about
crystal based life forms
you know what i mean which uh kind of
plays a big part in this
and the interesting thing about the
novel i've never read it but i was like
watching a couple of other things that
talked about the book in particular
and it's almost kind of like um it's
kind of like the book equivalent of like
found footage
he wanted it to be as realistic as
possible up to and including
even putting a fake bibliography in
there yeah like it has a fake
bibliograph this was supposed to be a
book that was talking about something
that really happened
and he had charts in there like i said
he had a bibliography in there that was
all fake
but sounded plausible and all this other
kind of [ __ ] because he wanted it to be
as realistic as possible so this is kind
of like
the book and the movie are very much
what i would call like hard sci-fi
this isn't one of those oh you know
martians come to earth and are blowing
everyone up
this is very much like this weird thing
is happening and now all these
scientists are gonna go through all of
this rigmarole and experimentation to
find out what's going on it shows pro
it's very procedural yeah and the
procedures are very accurate
with the intel community and [ __ ]
scientific community how they get
merged up with uh the military and
contractors agents that contract [ __ ]
out like how to build a secret facility
it's all in there now spoiler alert
you find out pretty early i guess it's
kind of about halfway through it
you find out that this thing is
extraterrestrial they hit a hit at it
they hint at it
because the um but this um
pathogen is crystalline and it comes
from space
yeah it was on like a um like a
satellite that
crashed or something like that and
that's it well because that's kind of
what happens at the beginning like this
satellite crashes and these guys go to
retrieve it
because this satellite crashed in this
little bitty town and all these people
dropped dead and they couldn't figure
out why
so then the two guys go to retrieve the
satellite but then they die and then i
think we
lost the stream maybe oh no okay
well i know i i was worried about it
because my chat like stopped a long time
ago
so um you know so i don't know if it's
going to wake up a little bit
okay it's weird because we haven't
really have been having much problem
with it lately yeah i mean [ __ ] we went
on for six hours friday night and didn't
lose it one single time
one of the weird things about this
crystalline pathogen is that it gets in
there and [ __ ] up
hemoglobin and turns your blood into a
solid dust
yeah it turns into like blood powder
turns into powder that's how it kills
you
and yeah it's pretty neat i mean the
thing about this movie
is that i kind of feel like this is one
of those ones you're gonna love it or
you're gonna hate it
it's as i said it's it's very hard
sci-fi so it's not like super
action-packed or anything
it's very much it's it's very grounded
and very science-driven it's not even
really it's not even really
driven honestly it's more like plot
driven and you're just trying to [ __ ]
like these scientists are
in this underground facility and you're
seeing them
go through all of the [ __ ] that they
have to go through to figure out
what the nature of this pathogen is um
you know
how can we stop it because it's is it
going to like kill all of these people
um you know and various other things so
there is kind of like
suspense there is kind of [ __ ] like that
you still go it's still going okay
just like let me know if it stops
because because my [ __ ] stopped
but um you know so so it's very much
like that so i can see how if you're not
really into that kind of thing
that people might think maybe it was
kind of like quote unquote boring or
slow
but i don't know i thought i thought it
was like really cool because it's like a
science mystery you know what i mean
yeah and it also
to me what was so um what i liked about
it is it shows
how procedural military and government
type
operations are even if it especially if
it involves things like
bio warfare and weapons of mass
destruction
very very structured there's a whole
system of safety imposed on everything
and security
as secrecy it gets into all that yeah
it's
so like i said it's really interesting
and in a way it's like it's really pro
science because it's showing you
i don't want to say it's like it's
showing you like the drudgery of science
but basically it's showing you this is
how you have to figure [ __ ] out it's
like it takes forever
it's not fun necessarily but it's just
kind of like we have to eliminate this
we have to eliminate this we have to
eliminate this because they don't know
what this thing is
and they think it potentially could be
dangerous and they're trying to prevent
it from getting out
so they're kind of just going through
all of these procedures
to figure out how to do that yeah i was
that kind of [ __ ] doesn't it didn't
impress me as much because i
i kind of take that for granted that
yeah you need to do
i liked all the supporting stuff like
all the money that they had to spend
to hide the fact that they built a
facility they get into
the that yeah leaves residue behind tire
tracks
and you know debris then you have to
spend money to erase the fact that
anything was ever built in this location
or roads going out through it
[ __ ] anything that could be seen on a
satellite all has to be erased
and then when you get there it does not
look like a facility it just looks like
a damn sheriff's office
yeah it was like it was for a department
of agriculture and they had like grown
all this barley out there
yeah make it look like it's got a total
cover story and when you go
in there you can't go hey i'm here
because the secret mission has activated
you go in there and they got old [ __ ]
andy taylor sitting there hey how y'all
doing you know reading the newspaper and
you got to have a specific
conversation with him that has nothing
to do with anything
yeah and then all of a sudden all right
and then he presses the [ __ ] button
and there's the elevator that goes down
it goes down to the secret to the secret
[ __ ] facility
and then the [ __ ] that's actually the
way they do a lot of that [ __ ]
okay and then the dudes that work at
those kind of places
are not being paid in the way that you
would think that there's like there's no
pay stubs
there's no record of these guys ever
[ __ ]
being employed that's when you know
you're [ __ ] deep
well yeah deep undercover because all
the scientists and doctors that they
call like the team
that they call like for whatever
specific reasons these are people that
have been briefed
on this secret facility which is called
wildfire
um you know i guess what's the name of
the project and also the the yeah
they don't know where it is or anything
about it they don't know anything about
it like they just know that
at any time if something happens then
they should be
activated and that's what like the first
part of the movie is
just these random scientists and doctors
like the military showing up and being
like
there's a fire wildfire then they're
just kind of like oh [ __ ] no they said
there was a fire yeah
never said okay i can't go right now
because there's a fire
remember that no wife wouldn't let him
in and and
we're having a party yeah and they
[ __ ] got guns and [ __ ]
and they're like uh look uh you know
he goes we have to see your husband and
um
we're going to come in yeah if you don't
bring it
so there's no choice yeah they signed
all these agreements and stuff
and you can't back out of it they can
use force to get your ass the only way
out of it is if you were sick
yeah because one of the guys actually
they didn't kind of imagine offhand yeah
the interesting thing about this
so michael crichton i don't this wasn't
his first book i think he'd written a
couple before this one but so he was
like pretty
he was a pretty well-known name and like
all his [ __ ] was you know uh was getting
adapted to movies like pretty
uh consistently now a lot of times they
would let him
adapt his own books but in this case
this was actually directed by robert
wise
who um fun fact well he directed a west
side story in the sound of music and a
bunch of other things too but he also
directed
my one of my very favorite horror movies
of all time which was the haunting
and um he didn't really want michael
crichton to not in a
shitty [ __ ] kind of way but he's like
well i kind of feel like when authors
adapt their own stuff
uh oh my god we just jumped right to
sexual tyrannosaur there's a certain
protocol that
okay
sexual tyrannosaur has been activated
we'll see if that's been activated there
might be a fire
smoke all right i like that i like how
that kind of ties in with the whole
thing here yeah
but yeah so uh so he was like well i'd i
find that when authors adapt their own
material like a lot of times they're
really resistant to any changes you want
to make and stuff so
uh robert wise actually got uh nelson
gidding who he'd worked
with before and who also wrote the
screenplay for the haunting which
obviously was an adaptation of the
shirley jackson novel
and he got him to do the adaptation
ironically
this movie is almost exactly like the
book
it is a very i mean even down to because
i think because the book was so found
footage like it was supposed to be like
a real document um you know oh this is
like declassified [ __ ] and here's like
all the documents and everything
so they decided to do it like a
documentary style
you know what i mean so it does kind of
have a little bit of that like i said it
does have a kubrickian kind of [ __ ]
going on too
but it splits green stuff yeah but it's
which is actually kind of cool yeah
i kind of like the way they uh they they
employed that
yeah there's one scene where they're
going there checking out [ __ ] ground
zero where
where where the pathogen uh uh broke
loose first
and you show they show one screen they
show them opening doors looking into the
apartments and then
they show in another screen what the
dudes saw and they're like dead dudes
dead little kids people dead in front
refrigerator just you know
it's kind of cool how they did that and
they had kind of like
didn't they have like [ __ ] marshall
music and [ __ ] with [ __ ]
snare drum oh yeah maybe now that i'm
thinking about it while they were
showing all that it was kind of creepy
yeah maybe maybe they didn't have that
because they were on a mission they were
just [ __ ]
and they're like real cold and
calculated just surveying who died
yeah they're going look at that oh wow
you know yep dead people
it's just their their job you know and
everybody just kind of dropped that
doing what they were doing
another fun fact all those dead people
were